Welcome, I'm
here. I'm going to be alone on this trip. I'm going to ask for drinks and food for everyone. I'm so nervous. And the
girl there. Is it me? Yes, let's have some
fun with us over here.
Stop it.
What's wrong with you? Stop it. You're the one who
can do this.  It's just Masashi-sama. I
thought it was Seshi's Roxy-sama. I'm sorry for deceiving you.
Roxy Heart. Please forgive that Roshi Heart Cob, the fifth generation mecha who supports the king.
Life is gold. If so, please
keep it here. He
will be feared by the people he is supposed to protect.
I am saddened and ashamed that I have become this kind of person.
Originally, a sage was supposed to protect the people. A
world where we could laugh together with the people. That was my father's
wish, and it is my wish. He
looks exactly like Mr. Mason.
Until my wish comes true [Music]
I will follow Roxy-sama [Music]